el concepto del número estético es muy
útil porque nos dice el número de
orbitales híbridos que tenemos así que
para calcular el número estético ok para
calcular el número estético tenemos que
sumar el número de enlaces sigmas y el
número de parejas solitarias que tenemos
de electrones ok así que si por ejemplo
tratamos de calcular esto para el metano
ok si quisiéramos encontrar el número
estético el número estético es igual al
número de enlaces sigma así que
fijémonos primero en nuestro carbono
verdad y tenemos cuatro enlaces sigma de
verdad tenemos aquí cuatro enlaces sigma
y no tenemos parejas solitarias de
electrones verdad por lo tanto nuestro
número estético que déjenme ponerlo con
el color morado que teníamos el número
estético será cuatro que son el número
de enlaces igm a más
pero parejas de electrones solitarias
verdad
lo cual nos da un total claramente de 4
y en el vídeo anterior vimos que
teníamos una situación en donde teníamos
una hibridación sp3 verdad entonces el
carbono tenía una hibridación sp3 de
hecho teníamos 4 orbitales híbridos y
eso es el número que necesitamos verdad
de hecho el número estético nos dice que
necesitamos 4 orbitales híbridos verdad
así que tomábamos de hecho un orbital
ese y 3 orbitales p y eso nos daba 4
verdad 4 orbitales híbridos esp 3 verdad
así que este carbono tienen hibridación
sp3 y de hecho en el vídeo anterior
también dibujamos todo todo lo que
pudiéramos verdad de esta de esta
molécula de metano verdad de hecho lo
que teníamos en el vídeo anterior era
nuestro átomo de carbono con sus 4
orbitales híbridos
y teníamos nuestros 4 orbitales
orbitales perdón híbridos con su
respectivo electrón y en cada electrón
perdón en cada orbital podríamos encimar
otro orbital es verdad que corresponde
al de los hidrógenos verdad ahí tenemos
más o menos una imagen de qué era lo que
teníamos con el metano verdad y
justamente donde teníamos el traslape de
estos orbitales entonces era lo que
podríamos decir que son los enlaces
simples o que también ya le conocemos
como enlace sigma y ahora que ya tenemos
esta imagen podríamos fijarnos en
digamos estas estas estas parejas de
electrones de verdad porque si nos
fijamos en ellos estos van a repeler se
los unos a los otros verdad y por
supuesto aunque sólo estoy marcando esto
lo mismo ocurre con las con cada con
cada pareja de electrones verdad y esto
ocurre porque las cargas iguales se
repelen verdad y ésta es la
idea central de esta teoría y de hecho
esta teoría se le conoce como la teoría
de repulsión de pares de electrones de
valencia verdad y que sólo para decirlo
digamos en corto diremos trm de muy bien
entonces esta teoría nos dice que estas
parejas de electrones van a tratar de
repeler se los unos con nosotros y van a
tratar de estar lo más alejado posible
de cada pareja verdad lo más alejado
posible en el espacio y esto significa
que el arreglo de estos de estas parejas
de electrones termina siendo tetraedro
verdad entonces vamos a notar esto
digamos la geometría de esta molécula
termina siendo te trae drica
hídrica
si quisiéramos pensar en la geometría de
la molécula por ejemplo si pusiéramos
nuestro carbono verdad y los electrones
los pusiéramos en términos de enlaces de
esta forma verdad estos electrones o
estos enlaces en realidad digamos hacen
que esta parte de la molécula digamos se
encuentre sobre la misma página verdad y
tenemos que poner una cuña para
representar que este hidrógeno en
realidad está saliendo hacia nosotros
verdad está apuntando hacia nosotros y
para representar exactamente lo
contrario ponemos una línea punteada
verdad que significa que está apuntando
digamos hacia atrás de la pantalla y de
hecho en digamos ya en la geometría
molecular resulta ser que estos átomos
también tienen una estructura de traer y
acá verdad tienen una geometría de traer
y acá muy bien de hecho podemos hallar
las cuatro caras de este tetraedro
digamos si pusiéramos que cada hidrógeno
fuera uno de los vértices de éste
pues ahí teníamos una cara otra cara y
al final vamos a poner esta que se va
por atrás nos da en las otras dos caras
que nos resta van así que tenemos dos
cosas que hay que observar la geometría
del grupo de electrones este trae drica
verdad mientras que también lo es la
geometría molecular del metano verdad
también este trae trico así que tenemos
un un ángulo entre los enlaces déjenme
déjenme marcarlo todavía más claro
tenemos un ángulo entre los enlaces que
vale alrededor de 109 punto 5 grados
verdad este ángulo formado por el átomo
de hidrógeno el de carbono y el de
hidrógeno es de aproximadamente ciento
9.5 grados y lo mismo puede uno decir de
todos los otros ángulos entre hidrógeno
carbono e hidrógeno muy bien muy bien
entonces vamos a hacer este mismo tipo
de análisis para otra molécula
vamos a hacerlo vamos a hacerlo para el
amoniaco ok entonces el amoniaco tenemos
un nitrógeno con dos electrones
solitarios junto a él y enlaces con tres
hidrógenos tenemos tres hidrógenos unido
a este nitrógeno si calculamos el número
estético podríamos ver lo siguiente
vamos a vamos a tratar de hacerlo el
número estético es igual al número de
los enlaces sigma verdad el número de
enlaces igm a que tenemos que en este
caso es 1 2 y 3 aunque tenemos tres
enlaces igna y hay que agregar el número
de parejas solitarias o de pares
solitarios que tenemos de electrones que
en este caso sólo es 1 entonces tenemos
un número estético de 4 verdad entonces
esto significa que el nitrógeno tiene
una hibridación sp3 verdad justamente
con el mismo argumento que mencionábamos
para
el metano verdad y decíamos que esto se
debe a que la hibridación sp3 nos da
cuatro órbitas orbitales perdón híbridos
así que vamos a tratar de dibujar esos
cuatro orbitales híbridos muy bien aquí
tenemos nuestro nitrógeno y ponemos
nuestros orbitales allí tenemos dos
y 4 muy bien y sabemos que hay un
electrón en cada uno de estos verdad
tenemos un electrón
un electrón un electrón pero además
ahora está esta pareja de electrones se
encuentran en un orbital verdad ahí lo
tienen y finalmente lo único que hay que
hacer es poner nuestros hidrógenos
verdad aquí tendríamos un hidrógeno
verdad otro hidrógeno y un tercer
hidrógeno verdad y sabemos que los
enlaces sigma corresponden justamente a
estos traslapes que hay entre los
orbitales verdad entonces esta es una
forma de dibujar el amoníaco así que
como en el caso anterior podemos
observar una geometría te trae drica
para este grupo de electrones verdad te
trae hídrica tenemos una geometría te
trae drica para este grupo de electrones
así que la teoría de tr el perdón
este ere acuérdense que es teoría de
repulsión de pares de electrones de
valencia nos dice que estos se van a
tratar de repeler verdad también van a
tratar de repeler sé
sin embargo la la figura o la geometría
de esta molécula vamos a vamos a tratar
de dibujarlo en otra imagen digamos
tenemos aquí nuestro nitrógeno y tenemos
los tres enlaces con los hidrógenos muy
bien ahí tenemos
tres hidrógenos y vamos a poner este
orbital que tiene los dos electrones
entonces la teoría nos dice que estos
van a tratar de repeler sea verdad y
éstos lo van a hacer con una mayor
fuerza sobre estos electrones que se
encuentran en los enlaces con los
hidrógenos verdad así que el arreglo
entre los átomos resulta ser que no es
tétrico debido a esta fuerza extra que
tenemos debido a los electrones sobre
este orbital verdad y todo eso tiene que
ver justamente con esta pareja de
electrones que tenemos por encima del
nitrógeno verdad está repeliendo estos
electrones en los enlaces con una mayor
fuerza que en el ejemplo anterior verdad
y eso va a obligar a que este ángulo
entre los hidrógenos pasando por el
nitrógeno disminuya este número de
ciento 9.5 de hecho el ángulo aproximado
en esta molécula de amoniaco
es de 107 grados y en términos de la
geometría de la molécula no decimos que
este trae trick tetraedro perdón si no
decimos que es piramidal tribunal así
que vamos a anotar eso esta tienen
geometría piramidal vida piramidal ok
piramidal tribunal muy bien y eso porque
eso porque se le llama de esta forma
bueno si piensas por ejemplo que
olvidamos por un momento estos
electrones en el orbital entonces
tenemos nuestro nitrógeno que está unido
a tres hidrógenos y vamos a
representarlo sólo con una bolita por
ahorita y entonces puedes pensar que
estos están más o menos unidos de esta
forma y considerando el nitrógeno como
uno de los vértices superiores del de
está justamente pirámide verdad a
diferencia del carbono que estaba dentro
de este tetraedro así que para concluir
tenemos una
el piramidal tribunal verdad es la
geometría de la molécula del amoniaco
pero es el nitrógeno que tiene una
invitación sp3 muy bien vamos a hacer un
ejemplo más
y vamos a considerar la molécula del
agua así que si recordamos tenemos un
oxígeno con dos parejas de electrones
que está unido a dos átomos de hidrógeno
verdad esta es la molécula de agua y
nuevamente si calculamos el número
estético tenemos que el número estético
es el número de enlaces y gmac que aquí
podemos observar que son dos tenemos dos
enlaces sigma y hay que sumarle el
número de parejas de electrones
solitarios que son dos parejas así que
nuevamente nuestro número estético
resulta ser cuatro y eso significa que
el oxígeno tiene una hibridación sp3 muy
bien así que nuevamente vamos a tratar
de dibujar cómo se vería esto tenemos
nuestro oxígeno con 4 4
orbitales híbridos ahí tenemos 3
entre un cuarto entonces podemos poner
un electrón aquí otro electrón acá y
estos dos tienen a los dos electrones
cada uno de cada uno corresponde a una
de estas parejas solitarias que están
junto al oxígeno verdad y finalmente
agregamos nuestros hidrógenos verdad
tenemos un hidrógeno aquí y tenemos otro
hidrógeno acá entonces los enlaces sigma
corresponden a estos traslapes entre los
orbitales y nuevamente el arreglo dentro
de estas parejas de electrones éste
traerá este tetraedro perdón
hídrico ahí lo tienen esta es la
geometría de los arreglos de las parejas
de electrones sin embargo este
nuevamente no es el caso de la geometría
de la molécula completa verdad porque si
pensamos en estos grupos de electrones y
los orbitales híbridos bueno la
geometría de la molécula es bastante
diferente así que vamos a tratar de
dibujarlo de este lado tenemos
nuevamente nuestro oxígeno que tiene
unidos los dos hidrógenos y ahí lo
tenemos y además tenemos nuestros
orbitales verdad que tienen estas
parejas de electrones ahí lo tenemos y a
diferencia por ejemplo del amoníaco aquí
teníamos solo una pareja de electrones
que estaba empujando a los él o más bien
repeliendo a los electrones que se
encontraban en los enlaces en este caso
tenemos dos parejas
electrones solitarios así que nuevamente
por esta razón va a estar cambiando el
ángulo entre los enlaces entre este
enlace de verdad entre estos dos enlaces
más bien este ángulo ya no va a resultar
ser ni siquiera de 107 grados de hecho
va a bajar todavía más y va a ser de
aproximadamente 180 105 grados por eso
es que a la geometría de esta molécula
se le conoce como geometría angular y si
tú te preguntas por qué es la geometría
angular bueno si omitimos por un momento
estos electrones podríamos pensar que
aquí está el oxígeno verdad que está
unido con dos hidrógenos verdad entonces
si tú te fijas en esta figura podrías
pensar qué forman un ángulo forme un
ángulo entre los dos hidrógenos y el
oxígeno así que aquí tuvimos tres
ejemplos de moléculas en donde el átomo
central en estas en estos tres ejemplos
tiene una hibridación sp3 así que esta
es una forma de más o menos descubrir la
la geometría molecular completa y para
pensar el ángulo entre los enlaces
verdad y también pensar cómo es que se
comportan los orbitales híbridos y cómo
es que toda esta interacción afecta a la
estructura de estas moléculas